the Joe Rogan experience that's one
thing that um I like talking to people
are telling people they're like oh
there's so difference of this and that
I'm a blonde like guys boxers
MLB MBA what NFL they had they had the
set schedule they have a set schedule
like I can sit down LeBron can sit down
before a year right when they announce
their first regular season he know
exactly what it's gonna be the whole
year boxers do the same thing they know
exactly we're gonna fight this month and
this month they don't know how to pawn
his name but after a fight they already
kind of know who they fighting you know
MMA fighters they're like don't you know
what's going on I have no clue right but
you see most fought to be yeah for the
title six days away when you were trying
to get down to 55 and they stopped you
when they stopped what did you weigh
when you started I was whenever we got
to call when I got there when I checked
in I was already uh the day before
weight check I'll tell you what I was
the day of the weight cut I was 170 170
day of the week Hut
and I and I tell you I'm not gonna tell
you exact number was before they stopped
me but I was like in reach like I was
right there but why did they stop they
came in the room they looked at me they
said they said oh yeah you don't look
good yeah we're cutting it I was like
what I feel good let's do it you know it
was right there and then uh does this
what they said you know it is they had a
real problem with New York in the
beginning I mean especially there's a
lot of people that just weren't prepared
for MMA I mean I I mean like I mean the
New York cards period don't have a lot
of luck at all and I heard then they
they go back to Brooklyn whatever was 20
fighting 28 card already scheduled and
that was a good fight yeah so they put
it in there yeah I know that guy you got
to keep Tony away from cables the day
before the fight Tony just someone needs
to just be around him all the time just
ready to catch him yes please miss this
is the fifth [ __ ] time they've
scheduled this fight hey you know they
say right
it's a great fight though I like can't
wait I cannot decide it I'm excited I
listicle II I think he's the best guy
that that could be observer face because
he can fight off his back
yeah he's a guy that doesn't survive off
his back he attacks me attack and he's a
guy just he just he throws a lot of
weird things from weird places like you
it's just hot it's hard like people
don't understand it like it's it's very
hard when you fight someone weird and
awkward evens pardon because you try to
get something and then he's like bang
here to an elbow but his head is like by
the ground is high level guy ever yeah
he's good he's real good he's real good
at his is his level though cuz I
consider him a world championship
caliber fighter and shows and at his
level I don't know of anybody that's
more unorthodox than him for sure
checking cardio man his cardio is crazy
off the chain off the Charles I don't
never seen anybody with cardio like that
I don't know what the [ __ ] it is do you
think that's genetic I to some extent
idea 100% I think you gotta have it
everybody keep telling me all you got
it's just like knock up are like you
can't road it but some people just have
a lot
[Applause]